Resuelve "x":
Y en este caso nos están dando, 4 que multiplica el valor absoluto de "x" más 10
más 4 y esto es igual a, 6 que multiplica valor absoluto de "x" más 10, todo esto más 10.
Vamos a hacer una cosa y vamos a
reescribir esta ecuación,
de tal manera que el valor absoluto simplemente brille y lo podamos ver fácilmente.
Vamos a poner entonces, tenemos 4 que multiplica el valor absoluto de "x" más 10...
y a esto le sumaremos 4...
todo esto será igual a 6...
que multiplica el valor absoluto de "x" más 10...
y a lo cual le sumaremos también, 10.
Se ve muy complicado, pero vamos a hacer primero
el despeje del valor absoluto de "x" más 10,
vamos a considerar esto tal vez como una variable, ok.
Tenemos 4 de algo más 4, que es igual a 6
de algo más 10.
Usemos esto como una variable simplemente.
Para que nosotros podamos eliminar este 6
del lado derecho porque vamos a pasar absolutamente
todas las variables del lado izquierdo,
tendremos entonces que restarle a este 6 valor absoluto de "x" más 10, pues le restaremos justamente 6,
valor absoluto de "x" más 10 y como es
una igualdad, aquí vemos el símbolo de igual,
haremos exactamente lo mismo del otro lado,
restaremos 6 valor absoluto de "x" más 10,
con eso hemos pasado las variables del lado izquierdo y ahora quiero las constantes del lado derecho,
este 4 es una constante, siempre será 4.
Para que yo pueda quitar este 4 del lado izquierdo, lo que haré es, tengo un 4 sumando entonces restaré 4...
y como lo que le hice al lado izquierdo, se lo he de hacer al lado derecho para mantener la igualdad,
restaré de este lado también 4.
Y con esto vamos a tener ahora, lo siguiente.
Si yo tengo 4 de algo y le resto 6 de ese mismo algo, realmente lo que estoy haciendo es quitarle a 4, 6.
Vamos a ponerlo más sencillo, si yo tengo 4 manzanas y le quito 6 manzanas, ahora tendré -2 manzanas...
bueno, creo que de hecho creo que ese ejemplo de las
manzanas tampoco nos ayuda,
vámonos con los números...
Si yo tengo 4 de esta variable y le quito
6 de esta variable, ahora tendré 2 negativo
de esta variable.
Vamos a pasarlo como tal.
-2 valor absoluto de "x" más 10...
este 4 positivo se cancela con este 4 negativo,
por lo que directamente nos iremos a la igualdad
y a propósito, lo que hicimos fue poner este
6 de la variable
y le restamos el 6 de la variable, ¿recuerdan?
es por eso que salió éste,
por lo tanto se cancela, tengo un 6 positivo y un 6 negativo de esa variable,
se cancelan y tendremos únicamente entonces esta resta, tengo más 10 menos 4,
es igual a más 6, vamos a escribirlo aquí...
es igual a 6 positivo.
Vamos avanzando, ahora lo que haremos es despejar esta variable, valor absoluto de "x" más 10.
Para ello, tenemos un -2 multiplicando, si
esto está multiplicando la manera en la que
podemos cancelarlos será dividiendo entre -2,
pero lo que le haga al lado izquierdo recuerda,
esto es una igualdad,
se lo he de hacer al lado derecho, así es
que dividiré entre -2.
Con eso tendremos entonces ,
la cancelación de estos dos
y nos quedará valor absoluto de "x" más 10, que será igual a 6 entre -2, igual a -3.
Y esto nos pone en una situación muy muy interesante,
recuerda que el valor absoluto es que tanta distancia tengo de ese número hacia el 0,
pero el valor absoluto tiene la propiedad de no negatividad, siempre será positivo.
Vamos a escribir eso, eso es importante.
El valor absoluto, siempre será positivo, por lo que tendría que ser mayor o igual a 0
y en este caso tenemos un -3, no hay posibilidad
alguna, que este número,
que es un valor absoluto, sea negativo,
dada la característica
o la propiedad que tiene el valor absoluto
de no negatividad.
Por lo tanto, esto simplemente nos dice que no tiene respuesta, no tiene solución posible.
Vamos a escribirlo, no tiene...
solución... posible...
y pondremos signos de admiración porque es
importantísimo que no lo olvidemos, ok.
Por lo tanto, esa es nuestra respuesta, esta
ecuación no tiene solución posible.